what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and moon knight episode
4 really made us go what the heck is
happening here for those of you who are
wondering what the heck was that ending
about don't worry we're going to break
it down and tell you everything you need
to know as well as break down some of
the key moments from this episode that
are very very important and of course as
it's been with moon knight so far
there's some ancient egyptian things
that we need to break down like the
hakka priests who were trapped inside of
the tomb for centuries how did they
survive all of those years and why are
they so bent on harvesting organs we'll
explain that ending and break down
everything you need to know in this
video and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so don't miss out on
any of the latest videos now the first
part that we're actually going to start
with is the ending because a lot of
people have no idea what is happening
here but they actually give us some big
major clues here to reveal kind of
what's going to happen in the next
episode and i really gotta give it to
marvel here they really did an excellent
job with this ending scene making us
wonder whether or not everything that
we've seen so far is actually real or
perhaps it's simply in the mind of mark
spector or steven grant and it was
simply made up now right off the bat if
you're wondering if everything that has
happened so far and taken place during
the moon night series is real or not
it's real and that's kind of the point
of moon night to make you think is this
person just mentally ill or is
everything that he's saying that he's
experiencing actually true is he the
avatar of konchu is he the moon's knight
this ending makes you wonder but let's
explain it in the tomb of alexander the
great arthur harrow shoots mark spector
in the chest twice he then falls
backwards into some water and begins to
sink down way down into what looks to be
an abyss and then it cuts to an old
movie and at first you have no idea what
is going on here it's an old indiana
jones type of movie and we find out
later on that it's called tomb buster
now the confusion slowly starts to go
away when you hear them talk about the
aztec goddess of the moon kind of
similar to konju who is the god of the
moon in egyptian mythology but then it
all clicks when we hear the name of this
main character of the movie and it is
steven grant the camera pans out and we
see that it's playing on a tv in an all
white room and we quickly realized that
this is a mental hospital a psychiatric
ward and we start to see some pretty
familiar people and things right away we
see a man with long blonde hair pull out
some bingo numbers out of a hat this is
steven's golden man friend the one that
he talked to in the first couple of
episodes and he's even holding the hat
that he seemingly used to collect tips
in the camera pans and we see somebody
playing with a rubik's cube just like
stephen would play with a rubik's cube
at night to keep himself up we then see
one of the workers who was actually one
of hero's agents she was one of the
persons who pretended to be a cop going
to steven's apartment and then took him
to harrow then she goes up to a patient
and the patient's name is donna and it
is steven's boss from work we then see
another worker who is beck who worked
for anton mogart last episode notice
that he's giving out cupcakes to
patients which is a direct reference to
episode 1 where stephen was driving the
cupcake van he gives one to a patient
who is drawing and if we look at the
drawing she's drawing a bird and the
head looks exactly like concho's head we
then see somebody in the reflection of a
window and we see the goldfish that
steven had in his apartment on the right
then a person comes into the picture who
was the other agent of hara who
pretended to be a cop that showed up at
steven's apartment and took him to
harrow and he says all right young man
the brakes are on and you're in your
favorite spot we then see oscar isaac in
a wheelchair he was very very confused
but a person quickly comes up to him and
this is layla and she mentions the movie
and says that she changed it because
they've watched it five times this week
already now steven is very confused and
he recognizes her and tries to call out
to her he tries to say layla but he is
sedated and can't really talk right now
as he has pretty much no control over
his body and it looks like layla is a
patient there as well she sees steven's
bingo card and says that he won but then
she claims that she won but promises
she'll share the prize with him implying
that he's won before and she's taken it
and kept it to herself now mark has no
idea what is going on but he looks into
his reflection and he calls out for
steven but steven's not there but he
gets up and tries to go to the
reflection calling steven's name out
again however he trips over an ankle
restraint and this is just like the
ankle restraint that he had in his
apartment that kept him from getting out
of his bed and running away when he
falls to the floor he actually has a
moon knight action figure in his hand
steven stares at the figure on the
ground terribly confused and then all of
a sudden we are in a new place this is
the office of a psychiatrist that we
know as arthur harrow and the first
thing that we hear him say is you've
been having a great deal of difficulty
differentiating between what is real and
what is in your head and here we really
are made to believe that stephen grant
actually is just suffering from a mental
illness and that he is actually making
everything up in his head but here's
where things start to take a turn and
where we can determine that this scene
right here this whole scene in the
hospital is actually fake now they
really do a good job at trying to
convince you it's real the doctor says
he borrowed the movie that steven
watches and even says that he liked the
villain and starts quoting things that
we've heard arthur harris say he says
the plot makes a big deal out of a lunar
god and then he says and didn't you say
you worked for one and as he's talking
mark is looking around and he's seeing
some things that are very familiar he
sees a picture of the swiss out
mountains which is where he was in the
first episode and he sees egyptian
artifacts everywhere and he sees
arthur's cane and the same slippers that
we saw him were before and you can see
him kind of start to think that wow he
is crazy he's mentally ill and you can
tell that a part of him is kind of
defeated but he snaps out of it when he
hears the doctor say i can't help you if
you don't help yourself because this is
exactly what arthur said right before he
shot mark and then he tries to escape
and the doctor says something very
interesting if you listen to his words
he talks about how he knows how it feels
to have a mental illness he says i know
i truly understand how you're feeling i
too have suffered from mental illness
breaks in psychic awareness depression
and it's interesting because it reflects
what arthur harrow is to mark spectre in
real life not this place because
remember arthur was the avatar of konchu
before mark so arthur in real life knows
what it's like to be conscious avatar
but mark manages to escape and he goes
down a hallway and this is the first
sign that none of this is real the
gravity sort of shifts in the hallway
it's almost like a scene from inception
the lights all turn to one side the
cards start moving down the hall but
steven runs down it the light's still
moving and he puts himself in a room to
hide and again another sign that this
hospital isn't real he goes inside the
room and finds a sarcophagus a
sarcophagus in which mark is inside of
the two of them are excited to see each
other but are also very confused about
how everything is happening and don't
worry i have thoughts we're about to get
to that but let's talk about this final
scene mark says that they need to get
out of there steven follows him as they
walk through the hall they actually pass
another room where the door is open and
we see another sarcophagus which is
moving much like how steven was inside
of the sarcophagus in the room that mark
went into he was kicking and screaming
to be let out of it and this is
basically the same thing and i believe
that there's another personality of mark
spector inside of the sarcophagus and i
believe that it is jake lockley in
episode 3 we found out that there was
another personality inside of the body
that mark or steven didn't actually know
about the person that stabbed and killed
those followers of harrow stephen said
he didn't do it and mark said he didn't
do it as well basically confirming jake
lockley who was another personality of
marx from the comics and i do believe
that this person inside of that
sarcophagus was jake luckily now as they
pass this room mark simply walks by it
but steven takes a look and even points
to it because he was just trapped in a
sarcophagus himself so he's clearly
wondering what's going on there but he
continues to follow mark until
eventually a giant hippopotamus pops out
of the doors and says hi in which
immediately steven and mark freak out
now who is this giant hippopotamus as
you might have guessed this of course is
an egyptian god and if you know who this
is here's where things kind of start to
come together sure you can say that
everything that we just saw in this
final scene was in steven's head in
mark's head and that he really is sick
and this is just a mental episode he's
having but let's be honest marvel
wouldn't do that to us plus in the
comics that's kind of a thing as well
but moon knight is proven to be real in
the comics and konchi has proven to be
real as well this is most likely taken
place inside of mark's mind as he kind
of dies remember he's died before and
konchu brought him back to life this is
probably something very similar that is
happening and i actually think that he
is kind of in some sort of a purgatory
here and here's the reason why that
giant hippo that giant hippo is actually
the egyptian goddess tauret tauret is
the goddess of fertility and
rejuvenation she was considered a
goddess of protection now her role in
rejuvenation was rejuvenation of the
dead which i think is going to be part
of how mark stephen kind of returned to
life her role was also to purify the
dead so they could go to the afterlife
which stephen actually mentions in the
very first episode he mentions the field
of reeds but before people can go to the
field of reeds they have to be judged
first and their heart weighed on the
scale implying that there is a place
they go before they can either go to
essentially hell or the field of reeds
which is essentially heaven and that's
where i think mark could be is it kind
of in his head as well probably but i do
believe that this god towerette is real
after all it is a show about egyptian
gods and we've already seen other real
ones which brings me to my next point
which is i think that yatsel the avatar
of hathor and hathor herself and other
gods are actually here to help episode
three made it very clear that there was
some type of relationship between koncho
and hathor plus not to mention yatsel
actually helped mark and in turn konchu
after the meeting they had where they
judged hero so it seems to be pretty
clear that yatsel and hathor are on the
side of mark stephen and konchu and they
probably believe that arthur is trying
to resurrect ahmet and that's obviously
really bad and the gods would want to
stop that also not to mention in this
episode it did show us a lot of other
gods that were turned to stone making it
very clear that this council that they
have is pretty quickly to judge and
probably some people in the council the
ones in charge like the avatar of osiris
probably aren't the best type of people
and if you defy them they'll probably
turn you to stone which is why i'm
assuming yatzel talked to mark in secret
but i do believe that some of the gods
are going to say yes arthur harrow is a
bad guy he is trying to resurrect ahmet
and we cannot have that so we need to
help konchu and mark and i believe that
tauret is one of those gods i believe
she's going to help mark come back from
the dead just like kanchu did and heck
maybe she'll even help kanchu escape so
everything we've seen so far that has
happened i do not believe that is fake i
do not believe that it was inside of
mark steven's mind but again kudos to
marvel studios cause they really do make
you believe that at first so that is the
ending explained but of course there are
other important parts to talk about of
this episode like in the beginning
scenes the last thing that we saw in
episode 3 was stephen and konchu turning
back the sky steven mentioned that it
was surprisingly painful which causes
him to pass out after it's done and then
of course konshu got turned into stone
now the very opening scene of this
episode is very peculiar we see the
avatar of osiris take the ubshanti of
konshu and put it in a wall that has
other statues of other gods turned to
stone and there were many many gods here
in the scene that were turned to stone
before konshu and it makes you wonder
what exactly did they do and i'm
starting to think that the avatar of
osiris and osiris the god and other gods
as well aren't exactly so good because
they didn't even really hear koncho out
konchu was just trying to protect the
world trying to stop arthur harrow from
resurrecting ahmet they didn't even
investigate at all they were like nah
it's fine he's cool and then after they
turned concho to stone they even let him
visit why now konchu said that the gods
turned their back on humanity the gods
kind of argued that humanity turned
their backs on them and this is very
interesting because perhaps some of the
gods could actually be bitter about this
and perhaps maybe some of them want
ahmet to be resurrected and want ahmet
to judge people it seems like the gods
kind of had enough of humans and maybe
ahmed is their answer to kind of get rid
of the bad ones and only leave the good
ones i'm assuming that something like
this is happening because i am
definitely assuming that some of the
gods aren't so good and i'm assuming
some of these gods that are turned to
stone in this scene are the gods that
went against them because they believed
that they were bad now as i mentioned
after konchu and steven turned back the
sky steven was left unconscious which is
where the beginning of the episode picks
up after layla manages to defeat some
bad guys steven finally wakes up and the
two of them get in the car together and
they go to amit's tomb and here they
confirm that steven slash mark no longer
has the suit layla says that was mark's
best feature but he doesn't even have
that anymore but she still tells steven
that mark is the one that is needed
right now they need the mercenary that
can kill however steven refuses because
he said they had a deal once conscie was
gone mark was gone and layla's pretty
pissed at that so leila and steven
decide to do this themselves which
steven is perfectly fine with because
one he wants mark completely gone but
two we all know that he's falling for
layla then layla and steven finally
arrive to the site in which arthur and
his men seem to already be inside of the
site they haven't found the tomb yet but
they are close so steven and layla look
for supplies before they go in and
steven has a conversation with mark and
this leads to a few events but mark
realizes that steven is indeed falling
in love with his wife but hey i mean
they're the same person you can't really
blame him but mark does threaten him and
says that if he touches her he'll throw
them off of a cliff it's also very
important to notice that mark does say
there's no more conscious there's no
more healing powers no more suit no more
protection and pretty much pleats his
case to get him to take over the body
but steven's not buying it because he's
got layla now as steven and layla are
gathering supplies it cuts to some
bloody crates and a bloody old knife now
eventually we do go on to find out what
these are so we'll talk about that in a
bit but of course we have to talk about
the scene that takes place right before
stephen and layla go into the site layla
goes in to kiss steven but steven is
such a good guy that before she can kiss
him he actually tells her the reason
mark has been avoiding her he says that
konchu wants her to be the next avatar
that's why he's been running away from
her to save her however leila says that
wasn't really his call to make she needs
somebody that's honest in which she says
that's steven's thing and steven takes
that as his sign to go in for the kiss
and he gets it and she seems to enjoy it
but she's also kind of weirded out
because it is her husband but it isn't
steven feels great though but mark
manages to summon enough power to make
steven punch himself in the face now
eventually layla and stephen make their
way down until they come into a room in
which layla discovers that the whole
place is amazed luckily steven is super
smart at this stuff and he realizes that
the maze is just an outline of the eye
of horus now steven's so smart that he
knows that the eye of horus is also the
eye of the mind and it represents the
six senses and there are six different
ways that they could take in this maze
therefore if they figure out the eye of
horus they figure out which way they
need to go now they realize that ahmed's
last avatar was a pharaoh and that
avatar would be the voice of ahmed since
it's ahmed's avatar so they determine
that they should follow the line that
symbolizes the tongue so they make their
way down that path and this is where
things get kind of interesting they
noticed that the wall shows depictions
of hakka priests laila states that they
would have been put in the tomb with the
pharaoh so they could protect the
pharaoh's body she also explains that
they were sorcerers of their time and
this is very very important now hecka is
an egyptian god heka is the god of magic
and medicine in ancient egypt which is
why she says hakkas priests are
sorcerers and the next scene really does
kind of prove that they were indeed
sorcerers now since stephen and laila
had entered this site they had noticed
blood on the floor and gun shells on the
floor and they were wondering what
exactly hero's men could be shooting at
well as it turns out they were actually
shooting at some of these priests who do
seem to be magic otherwise how would
they survive over the centuries that
they've been around and it looks like
they are doing exactly what they are
supposed to do be protecting the
pharaoh's tomb as these creatures are
literally attacking hera's men and
bringing them back and taking out some
of their organs now in ancient egyptian
times priests of aka were actually the
doctors because back then they believed
magic and medicine were somewhat of the
same thing they believed that if a
person got sick it was because of a
demon or a bad spirit or it was the will
of the gods essentially something
supernatural caused them to get sick so
they needed something supernatural to
fight being sick to get better enter the
magic doctors now why is this person
collecting the organs of people well we
don't really know at this point in time
but perhaps there is a pharaoh that is
still alive out there or perhaps there
is a god that these priests are
collecting these organs for but
regardless these people do seem to be a
problem for everyone here arthur's
people and stephen and layla steven
manages to squish one but layla
encounters another one in a very indiana
jones tomb raider type of scene so it
appears that there are more than one
after all leyla said that there would
have been multiple ones as the painting
showed us layla seems to have a thing of
using flares to defeat bad guys so
that's what she does and she manages to
make it to the other side of this
mind-like area now from here there are
two major scenes that we need to focus
on we're not focusing on the very end
because we've already talked about that
but two main scenes here and the first
one is of layla and harrow he tells
layla the truth but the first thing to
notice is that he says the name of
leila's father abdullah el fowley now
this could actually be extremely
important it is a big easter egg and
could lead to layla actually becoming a
superhero you see in the comics there
was a person with a very similar name
abdul faul the names are very similar
and in the comics he is an archaeologist
but he is also the egyptian hero known
as scarlet scarab now he has to be in
possession of the ancient artifact known
as the ruby scarab in order to harness
its power which consisted of superhuman
strength durability flight and the
ability to drain others powers during
world war ii abdul protected the
egyptians during that time until one day
the scarab vanished he spent the rest of
his life searching for it but he never
found it now on his deathbed he told his
son about it and told him to continue
the search and eventually he did find it
and he became the second scarlet scarab
now obviously they changed things a
little bit here but think about why they
would do that because in moon knight's
origins the love of his life is marlene
and her father was dr alren and they
completely changed that origin here so
why did they change it could it be so
that maybe one day in the mcu layla
could be the scarlet scarab after all
arthur haro does say that her father
used to call her my little scarab huge
easter egg here and i think layla is an
excellent character and really wouldn't
mind if she became a superhero now on
top of all this we do hear the original
origin story of moon knight arthur says
he's going to tell layla the truth and
that mark knows the truth but won't tell
her he says that her father was murdered
by mercenaries and nobody knew who they
were but mark was there and he remembers
everybody now we get the full story of
this in the next scene when layla
confronts mark but first mark arrives to
the tomb as soon as he enters he says
that this pharaoh is gonna be one of the
big ones but he could have never
imagined who it was going to be mark
immediately recognizes that it's
macedonian writing on the tomb and the
only pharaoh that was macedonian was
alexander the great so steven just
starts to freak out now alexander the
great was a king of the ancient greek
kingdom of macedon and he is considered
to be one of the greatest military
leaders of all time by the age of 30 he
had created one of the largest empires
in history and he never lost a battle
and he was in many many battles he is
still studied today by military leaders
but here's the thing his tomb was
actually lost to this day scholars
cannot tell you where exactly the tomb
of alexander the great is a lot of
people over time have claimed that
they've found it but they've all been
disputed so the exact location right now
pretty much remains unknown even though
last year in 2021 egyptian officials
claimed that they had found alexander
the great's tomb in siwa oasis which is
where alexander the great wanted to be
buried but scholars will say that he was
not actually buried there and the
location of his tomb is still unknown so
this is a really cool thing that they
throw into moon night here now mark
tells steven that he has to take the top
off of the tomb and he has to look for
the ushabti he's got to get it before
hero does and steven states that if
you're going to hide it for all eternity
you probably put it in a place where the
average looter wouldn't think to look
now what's important to note here is
that layla and steven in this episode
determined that ahmet's last avatar was
a pharaoh so in the mcu alexander the
great was amit's avatar so the ashapti
is on alexander the great somewhere and
steven determined since alexander the
great was the avatar of ahmet he was the
voice of ahmed so he probably hid the
ushabti down his throat and as it turns
out he was right he finds the ushabti
which is a stone statue of amit so just
like konshu and other gods were turned
into stone so was amit and this is what
harrow needs to bring her back to life
now we know that they can come back to
life because konchu told stephen right
before they turn back the sky when
kancho knew that he was going to be
turned to stone he told steven to tell
mark to save him so clearly this can be
reversed so stephen and mark finds it
but their celebration is cut short
because layla is there and demands
answers from mark mark comes out and
tries to get layla to leave but layla
thinks that he might have killed her
father so she demands answers mark says
of course i didn't kill your father but
he was there he was one of the
mercenaries and here's the full origin
story of how mark specter in the comics
becomes moon knight mark says that my
partner got greedy and he executed
everyone at the dig site which of course
layla's father was a part of and was
executed this is what happens in the
comics mark's partner bushman ends up
killing archaeologists and then mark
stands up to buschmann but bushman
defeats him and this is pretty much what
he tells layla here he says i tried to
save your father but i couldn't save him
and he says that he shot him too and he
was supposed to die that night but he
didn't die that night now he doesn't say
so to layla here but this is how he
becomes moon knight in the comics
bushman shoots him and he actually does
die but he dies right in front of a
statue of konchu and konchu revives him
brings him back to life under the
condition that he be his moon knight the
fist of konchu and that's how moon
knight is born and it sounds like the
story is pretty much the same in the mcu
however the only exception is in the
comics although the people are different
the archaeologist's daughter was
actually at the site and she witnessed
everything go down clearly layla was not
there as she does not know what happened
but it looks like mark met layla because
he felt so bad about her father being
executed he wanted to track her down to
apologize to her but he couldn't he
couldn't bring himself to tell her but
she realizes this and she says this is
why we met mark just had a guilty
conscience now they're about to get into
it even more but arthur and his men they
come layla hides but mark doesn't go
down without a fight he grabs the
pharaoh's axe which actually looks
exactly like moon knight's grappling
hook from the comics the markings are
even kind of similar mark kills a couple
of heroes guys but then harrow shoots
him twice in the chest and it looks like
he dies and of course you have heard my
opinion on this because we started by
talking about this ending here so be
sure to let me know your thoughts about
this episode in the comments down below
were you freaked out by that ending and
where do you think mark and steven are
right now leave your comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel videos for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
you